Problem 16.
Use the diagram below
to answer the
question that follows.
This diagram, which
is n by 2n.
Maybe they want us to do some
type of area or something.
They shaded in this triangle,
which is about 1/2 of it.
It's exactly 1/2 of the area.
Let's see what they
want to ask us.
The diagram above could best
be used to derive a formula
for which of the following
quantities?
Interesting.
All right, the sum
of the first n
consecutive odd integers.
Now does that make any sense?
Let's see, we have n here, and
they say the sum of the first
n consecutive odd integers.
Let's see, if we look at the
shaded area, if we look at the
height here-- that height here
is 1-- the height of this next
column, right here, is 3.
The height of the next
column is 5.
Every column is incrementing
by 2, so these are the odd
integers, and there are going
to be n of them, right?
One, two, three, four, all
the way to n of them.
And so if we wanted the sum
of them, we would have
essentially just to figure out
the area of the shaded region,
so we could use the
diagram for that.
So, the area of the shaded
region is 2n times n divided
by 2, which is equal
to n squared.
Which is a neat outcome by
itself, that the sum of the
first n consecutive odd
integers is n squared.
So that's going to
be our choice, A.
You can actually use
the diagram to
figure out that formula.
The other ones don't
make sense.
The product of the first n
consecutive even integers.
I don't see where you
get even integers.
There's a 1 and a 3 and a 5.
So anything with even
doesn't make sense.
And then choice D tells us the
product of the first n
consecutive odd integers.
But I don't see how this is
helping you visualize what
happens when you multiply
1 times 3 times 5
times 7, and so forth.
Next problem.
Problem 9.
Use the diagram below
to answer the
question that follows.
OK, it looks like some type
of lattice multiplication.
The diagram above demonstrates
how the lattice multiplication
algorithm is used to multiply--
I was right, it's
lattice multiplication--
multiply 231 by 25 to get the
product 5,775.
What value does the circled
digit represent?
So, if lattice multiplication
looks like something
completely foreign to you, you
just have to-- well, I'll give
you a quick primer on it.
All you're doing, each of
these boxes, you're just
multiplying the corresponding
digit.
So 1 times 2 is 2.
0, 2.
3 times 2 is 0, 6.
2 times 2 is 0, 4.
1 times 5 is 0, 5.
3 times 5 is 15, 1 5.
2 times 5 is 10.
And then, you add up the core,
the different places.
So this is the 1's diagonal,
right here.
You have just a 5 there.
You get a 5.
This is our 10's diagonal,
right here.
So it's 20 plus 0
plus 50 is 70.
And then this is your 100's
diagonal, 600 plus 100 is
equal to 700.
So I just answered
your question.
They said, what does the circled
digit represent?
Well the circled digit is in
this hundreds diagonal, so it
represents 100.
Now, if that still is kind of
unfamiliar and you're like, oh
gee, how was I supposed to know
about this 100's diagonal?
You could think about
it this way.
This 15 right here is the
byproduct of multiplying that
3 and that 5.
Right?
3 times 5 is 15.
And then they circled the 1.
But what is this, really?
This is really a 30.
Right?
This is 231.
So this is really 30 times 5.
This is just a regular 5.
30 times 5 is equal to 150.
So this 15 is really
representing 150, or this 1 is
really representing 100.
And that makes sense because
it's in that 100's diagonal.
So once again, our answer
would be C, 100.
Problem 18.
Use the samples of a student's
work below to answer the
question that follows.
Which of the following
statements best describes the
mathematical validity of the
algorithm that the student
appears to be using?
So let's see what the
student's doing.
9/16 divided by 3/4.
He or she is just dividing the
numerators and then dividing
the denominators.
Now that's not the standard--
the traditional way-- that,
you know, most of us are taught
of doing division of
fractions, right?
The standard way, if we have
a/b divided by c/d-- or at
least the way I learned to do
it-- I would say that this is
equal to a/b times d/c, times
the reciprocal of this.
And I would have gotten that
it's equal to ad over bc.
This is the standard.
This is the standard
algorithm.
Now let's see, this guy over
here, if he takes a/b and he
divides it by c/d, what he's
getting essentially for the
new numerator, he takes
a/c, and for the new
denominator he takes b/d.
And if you were to simplify
this-- a/c divided by b/d--
this is the same thing as a/c
times d/b, which is equal to
ad over bc.
So even though this looks very
bizarre and actually very
naive, because he's just
dividing the numerator and
dividing the denominator,
it works.
This'll work for any numbers
that you put in there.
And so, let's see,
A isn't right.
It is definitely, you know,
try doing this the
way you know it.
You'll get these same answers.
So A isn't it.
It's definitely, well,
here you go, D.
It is valid for all rational
numbers, as unintuitive as
that might be.
But it looks like this kid, oh,
he just said oh, I'll just
divide the numerators and divide
the denominators just
because multiplying fractions,
you kind of do the same thing.
But it just happens to work.
In fact, this is probably
how they should
teach it, or maybe.
Arguably how they might
want to teach it.
Problem 19.
Use the inequality below
to answer the
question that follows.
OK, maybe it's an inequality.
Which of the following
inequalities describes all
possible values of x?
So let me write.
So they're writing 3/x
is greater than 4/x.
So, if we assume-- well x can't
be equal to 0, because
that would just be undefined.
So let's just write that down.
x cannot be equal to 0.
So to solve this equation, we
can multiply both sides by x.
We have to be very careful,
though, because if x is
negative, and you multiply both
sides by it, you'd have
to switch this inequality.
But let's just assume
x is greater than 0.
If x is greater than 0, then
when you multiply both sides
of these, of this equation, by
x, you don't have to switch
the inequality, and then you
get 3-- let me put it in a
different color-- if you
multiply both sides of this
equation by x, you get 3 is
greater than 4, which is
definitely, this is false.
This cannot be true.
So x cannot be greater than 0.
So let's see what happens
when x is less than 0.
If x is less than 0, then when
you multiply both sides of
this equation by x, you have to
switch the inequality sign.
So then you would get
3 is less than 4.
Which is definitely
true, right?
What I did is just multiplied
both sides of this by x.
When you multiply both sides
of an inequality by a
negative, you have
to swap this.
That's why the greater than
became a less than.
These canceled out.
So you got 3 is less than
4, which is true.
So any x less than 0
will satisfy this
equation, right here.
So then you could try it out
as, you know, minus 3/4 is
greater than minus 4/4, right?
You could try it out with any
numbers that you might like.